I'm making large changes to my LIFE GOING FORWARD.
2027 IS THE YEAR THAT WE'RE going to get it all right, guys.
We're cutting all the toxic people out of our lives. We're leaving
all the toxic people in 2026.
Say the line, Bart. SAY THE LINE, BART.
>> SAID HE has a good reason never to be doxed. He does
this to shield his
>> Jstock didn't tell me that. Queenman didn't tell me
that. Doobie didn't tell me that. I thought that
>> So, if you guys missed it, Counter-Points had a stream
today and he was talking to Doobie and then I think that eventually
Destiny hops on. Doobie will make a point of, "Okay, well, when
Destiny doxes people, he's putting people's family at risk and
he's like creating what we call a permission structure or a a
possible lens by which people will judge him and act against
him, right? That what we principally don't is sort of losing
his moral high ground should defend me against these these kinds
of actions, right?" Well, they think that YOU CAN USE YOUR SEXUAL
POWER AND CLOUT AND influence and money in order to mentally
women.
Give me one example.
Anna Vor. So, so hold on. You think Jstock, Queenman, Esports
Batman, they all hate you for delusional or non-serious reasons.
Yes.
Uh I Okay. That's crazy. >> Okay, dude. Because you are
reaping what you've sown. You are reaping what you've sown and
you haven't learned your lesson and it sucks. Okay, in my current
court case drama, who what is the what what is the stone part?
What did I sow here? Was it immoral It wasn't immoral for you
to have sex with Pixie. It was immoral for you to take her homemade
and said it to somebody that you'd only known for 10 days. Are
you going to tell me how to run my personal life? No, but if
anybody was your friend, they would tell you an idiot to your
face, which is what I'm doing right now. You are an idiot. You
are dumb. You ruin your own life. I see my friend who's a
up and I've tried to be nice about it and that's not working.
So I'm going to be mean about it. You don't know how to manage
your relationships. Anytime anybody challenges you on anything,
even if they love you, you run away because you're afraid of
growing up. But you are such a
that it is impossible to be your friend. It's impossible to be
your partner. It is impossible to tell you that you're wrong.
It's impossible for you to take a L. I might have to check out
these logs. I'm being told Destiny's crash out is like crescendoing.
Hold on. We'll do We'll do a quick look right now, okay? We're
on the back of last night where it's revealed that Destiny is
in fact age playing
a woman whose husband is a groper.
He's this person.
Almost 40. I'm worried for you. Just get your own side. You're
just not very grown up. What do you want me to say? That's a
personal problem. Don't take it out on me, Connor.
Grow up. You're 40. Grow up. Connor, you are on the internet
talking about You are age playing with a groper's
wife.
Well, that's pretty you know.
the thing is is Here's the thing. Would that be enough to make
Connor crash out? I don't know. Maybe. It might be. But there
was another log here that I responded to earlier today on Twitter,
okay? When you get these logs today from Destiny, these other
two people are not public people at all. But I'm sure their friends
and people they know are watching. So for me to say anything
at all about this particular situation will take all of their
personal business up and throw it into the public light. Why
would anyone ever subject someone to that? Both of the parts
of that couple were literally begging Connor to stop leaking
/ publicizing anything. From experience, anytime Destiny invokes
somebody else's privacy
in any way, whenever he goes, "Oh, you need to respect this person's
privacy. NO, NO, YOU'RE GOING TO YOU'RE GOING TO INVADE THEIR
PRIVACY. NO, I'M I'M WORRIED FOR THEIR SAFETY." When Destiny
leads with like empathy for another person, that is always automatically
a shield for some like egregious behavior he's engaged in. He's
never once been concerned about people's privacy. Just look at
what he's getting sued for.
Like literally take 2 seconds, give your head a shake, and think
about what the this idiot is getting sued for, right? It's so
obvious. It's so obvious. Honor has been bending if not breaking
his own principles for the sake of Destiny's online reputation.
For Destiny to to talk to him and start asking for more is what
broke Honor off. When Destiny said he was entitled, boom, glass
shattered. Yeah, when Destiny said you people are so entitled,
absolutely.
Honor leaks intimate DMs.
And you know what? >> Wait, what? >> I'll say this,
too. BPD girl, her message to me is, "Oh my god, please stop.
He's never going to talk to me again."
>> I By the way, I Connor is still There's like levels
to deprogramming.
And I know Listen, I know people I'm like think I'm motivated
in doing this. I'm really not, but people think it's like me
just having motivated reasoning and wanting to do this or something.
It's not. But that is a part of the framing that allows this
kind of a like abuse to take to continue over time, right? I'm
just
Anyway, that's what's going on. Steven casually engages with
mentally ill women. Jeez.
Dark. Little dark.
Feels kind of dark. >> You're pretty crazy.
We got to keep going, man. There's too much. There's too much.
There's too
So annoying. He is not representing anything of this person correctly,
but he is dragging so many people's business out into the public
eye, and it is impossible to talk about it without just outing
so many people's business. I hope after Connor finally implodes,
he at least haunts the right person.
I wonder who the right person is. I feel like I'm in his head
just from this just from this mistype right here. I'm like I'm
literally in his head from this mistype. I almost dropped the
divorce thing right there.
Well, W, oh, he's just reacting to um the Hutch stream. By the
way, both the Striper and his wife were begging Connor to [__]
off last night and to stop dragging their business out in the
open. I don't need recommendations from you for how to run my
life. Number one. Number two. >> Yes, you do, you dumb
because you keep burning your own life. Number [snorts] two,
I'm not the one who needs social worker. Holy [__]
you're so ass pain over your obsession with my life. No, I'm
not, you Okay, fine. Just shut up. Shut up. I'll just say it.
I'll just say it. After you leaked homemade
After the entire internet hate Oh, wait, this is the point I
wanted right here, okay, to keep reading the logs. You started
with another woman on Discord. Are you And you [__]
did age play with Wait. I
am a little confused.
Dude, Hutch
Hutch consistently is like the worst reactor that exists. Like,
dude, this is like such awful content, man.
And he had 4,000 viewers or something
He pauses perfectly to cut off the point to go, "Ah, I'm like
a little confused. I like, what's going on here? Like,
Wow, what's going on, man? Wow. How did this come up again? If
it's like the conversation about the snarky people, why did this
come up again?
Because when Destiny tries to portray himself as the victim,
he has to lie completely. Hutch, welcome to your life. Hutch,
this is the ghost of your Christmas future right here, okay?
You're going to defend some of this conduct. You're going to
realize that the people who are upset, this is the infinite Destiny
cycle, okay? It's why he can't maintain any relationships.
You're going to realize that when you swept for this in about
a year, maybe a year and a half, you'll realize that sweeping
for this was a huge mistake and you'll feel like a complete [__]
you'll be in Connor's position cuz Destiny will have like changed
his story on all of this stuff. It'll all be way different to
meet whatever new crazy [__] he's done. And Connor
understands that basically his criticisms from before are being
laid out as insane. Like he's totally switched his positions
from before. Connor is saying the same thing he was 1 year ago.
But now because because of how Destiny's approaching the situation,
now even though Connor's saying the exact same thing he was a
year ago, he's suddenly a liar. He's like a liar who wants to
destroy Destiny's life and is obsessed with Destiny's [__]
Very cool. >> and she was MARRIED TO SOMEONE ELSE. AND
SHE WAS MARRIED TO A GROPER.
SHE was married to a groper.
Do you think it is prudent to
text message somebody who's married to a
I Connor, aren't you divorced? Do I need to pass
>> Oh my god. through every single person that messages
me with a nude or wants to send Is that what I need to do Do
I need to get permission from you from now on? Are you going
to tell me how to run my personal life? No, but if anybody was
your friend, they would call you an idiot to your face, which
is what I'm doing right now. You are an idiot.
You are dumb.
You ruin your own life. Okay. All right. Does any What is happening?
I I shouldn't laugh because it's a deliberate strategy, right?
Hutch I don't know how How deliberate [clears throat] is it from
Hutch? It's like a deliberate strategy to go like, "This is crazy
and like should be private. You shouldn't talk about any of this
in in public at all." But Destiny constantly makes this stuff
public. Constantly makes this stuff public, okay?
And he is not somebody who could be held privately accountable.
If he was, I'm sure he would have changed before.
Right? This how he demonstrates how normal he is. I know that's
what he's trying to do, but it's like it's an actual real like
problem that Hutch wants to pull this up and he he's playing
into a system he doesn't understand, which is I mean, probably
his entire life, really. So, hard to get like too angry at him.
I just I I just get annoyed cuz the content is dumb. Like he
just pauses and goes, "This is so online. I don't even know what
the dude you watch this 8 hours a day."
That's what we're doing here. >> being sued for leaking
homemade
Should you start text messaging a woman who's married to a political
opposition that hates your
Connor, at this point >> sane or normal behavior? >> the
world hates my guts, Connor, but what I do with my >> Wait,
okay, so the whole world hates YOUR GUTS. HOW DO YOU KNOW IT'S
DOOBIE SWATTING YOU? >> do Connor, what I do I've never
said that Doobie himself swatted me. Birdman, thank you. What's
How do you know it's a
Because these guys literally have the slogan at the beginning
of their Wait, wait, but but but but the Hutch Uh Doobie didn't
It's so awesome that it's so awesome
that this has come out now that there's like a reason like we
could basically point to. It was always like this. But basically
it's like Destiny was sort of tying the group to KF or something.
And if he has if he has like a website zero element here where
he knows that there are other people who are trying to do this
stuff to him, and he's still blaming this like he he was already
doing it with KF, okay? But if he's doing it to an extra degree
again, he's just full-on Keppels lolcow
That's awesome. You love to see it. Like there's I just wasn't
prepared for it to go to that extent, okay? I was I didn't think
that's what the way it was, but that do be how it is, Mr. Stansel.
It do be like that. Mr. Stansel. >> Speak up in chat, and
I didn't realize I could I clicked on his name on the super chat
and it didn't give me the option to hide user from channel. It
just let me I don't know what I'm talking about. I don't want
your money, Doobie.
But the husband Buttermilk with the tier one membership, thank
you. Was in a telegram where groupers were plotting your murder.
If they were plotting your
then don't you think they might swat
I don't know, they might, but I've gotten swatted so full You're
so You are full of
You are so full of [__] You want You want to blame
Kweiman, Jay Stalk, all of these people for what What does Kweiman
and Jay Stalk
What is Oh, the timestamp. Yeah, it's coming up. 2 minutes. What
is What is What is What is What is What is What is What is Dude,
it's so I I'm sorry, it's like he I have no patience for people
who are like intentionally ignorant or or willfully ignorant.
I have no patience for it. Like you've talked about this guy
enough. Learn how to say his name. That's all you got to do.
Just learn how to say the name. It's not a Stop. And yet you
always poke the bear. You always
You It's EVERYBODY ELSE'S FAULT. EVERYBODY else's fault. It's
never Destiny's fault. It's never s- I just What does What does
Kweiman have to do with um like
life? Well, you see, Hutch, it started one day in an Euler call.
We loaded up some videos.
Sorry, that's a that's a joke that's hinting at like an old thing
Destiny used to accuse us of that was obviously like stupid.
That's a joke. That's a joke. That's a joke. That's a joke. What
What is the connection there? Um am I missing lore?
Very I'm very confused. Um Jen with the year, thank you so much.
Appreciate
Steven Salt
He manages to perfectly pause in these
to prevent or sorry, to prevent understanding. Like he pauses
explicitly in a way that stop his ability to understand the situation.
Like when Connor first mentions the age play Hutch is like pausing
as it's being said and he doesn't get it.
He doesn't understand, doesn't hear it all. Yeah, we can't do
a moral inventory >> Caramel Colbert with $20, you deserve
a donno for being fair and balanced. What the You're doing every
single Who does Hutch talk to from the other side of this issue
at all?
Fair and balanced. Fair and balanced. >> You don't have
to talk to me if you don't want to, but you should probably talk
to somebody who knows any of this stuff, right?
Like Hutch just doesn't care. Lots of people can lay this out.
Hutch just does not give a
Connor. Like there is a context where
if I was like Destiny's friend, like if we were close like that.
And again, this comes from like recovery, the Oh, I think Hutch
Hutch does some stuff about tying this into recovery. It's like
he's
This is he's he's basically become like a another Notsocreative.
Notsocreative basically put Destiny in this box of like traumatized
person who could do no wrong and he was good they were going
to be infinitely charitable to. What Hutch I I defended Hutch
when he said this originally. Like, okay, Hutch didn't really
know what was going on. He wasn't going to look into it. He wasn't
going to take a side. He just said, "Hey, I know that he's like
hurt this person and I'm not going to cut him off forever, but
it seems like a toxic situation and I do believe in redemption,
so I'm not going to say I would cut him off forever, right?"
And then he just started talking about how everything had changed
without explaining what had changed ever. Right? He doesn't have
a good idea of what has changed. He's just sort of rationalized
the things that are convenient for him. The things that basically
give him money, clout, influence, viewers, all of this stuff,
right? He's rationalized moving in that
Oh well, things really changed. Okay, what changed? What has
changed?
What do you think's changed, Hutch?
It pisses me off because the idea that you're even even the idea
that because the signal you can't say the signal, right? Like
I actually know how to say his name. You couldn't say it. Can't
say I actually know. It's when you feign that ignorance to make
the signal, it annoys me. It's like honestly, even if you
I don't even care about doing that. If you want to signal somebody's
opinion is not valuable, do that. But the idea that you're like
stupid to do it annoys me. The recovery relationships that you
make when when you start going to like NA meetings and working
a program,
the culture is to use like very blunt language. Oh, yeah, this
is the problem is you've got an addict who's never able to hit.
Actually, here is the analogy that Hutch needs. You have an addict
who is not even close to hitting bottom, and you've got a bunch
of people like you Hutch are participating in this right now,
who are holding him up, right? This person basically cannot get
better. They're very harmful in the current state they're in.
They cannot get better without hitting rock bottom, and you are
one of the people holding them up. Right? You're the one of the
people who's going to sacrifice your reputation, sacrifice your
happiness ultimately to hold them up, and
I you can't see it, but it's happening.
Right? He has to admit he has a problem. Yeah, exactly.
The admission of the problem is required to and that's the thing
that annoys me about Hutch actually, because
he said like as long as this guy's on the path to redemption,
I could forgive him. And I just want to know what indication
has there ever been that Desi's on the path to redemption, that
he is sorry for what he's done, that he's attempting to do any
sort of penance or
like payback any of the harm he's done in the world, right? To
not recompense, but to like give any restitution back to the
people he's hurt. There's there's just nothing. He's not trying
to make amends. And I do think that's an important part of a
program, right? Is to let people know you you did hurt them.
Their their feelings like towards you were valid. You had a problem.
But Destiny can't do that. He's incapable.
Why I said penance first. There's a word I'm looking for, but
um
Anyway, like that is critical to being forgiven and starting
to get better. And Destiny hasn't hit that bottoming out point
where he's going to apologize to people who he's harmed and try
to get
Yes, he doubles down and goes on the attack. Exactly.
And like I could frame this in Hutch's way. I don't like him
because he's actively harmful to people, right?
But I can frame it in that way for Hutch. I I don't think he
would even try to understand that, right? Not even a little bit.
He would never try to understand that. I think Connor and Destiny
were like legit friends outside of streaming, so I assume they
talked about this stuff. I'm not really sure. And and like superficially,
yes. Like it is appropriate sometimes to tell your friends, just
like I said a minute ago. It is sometimes appropriate to say
like, "Hey,
there's one thing that all of these things have in common and
it's that it involves you. And so you [clears throat] probably
need to look at yourself. Like that's a perfectly reasonable
comment. I another thing going on here is that Destiny's actually
just like a pathological liar. And so like if you try to confront
him on something,
you'd need like all of the people present who are involved in
the situation.
Because otherwise, he's going to have a he has a very good idea
of how to compartmentalize information. Nobody's told specific
people but specific things and he will he will just
And so that is probably his biggest, you know, where people see
the most into how he operates is when he like things are litigated
publicly because he can't go backwards, right? Hutch doesn't
know enough. He shouldn't be covering this. Otherwise, it's just
going to be him sweeping. Well, he is going to sweep. The real
problem here would be Hutch not willing to speak to somebody
who has the facts, right? Like Hutch probably should be willing
to talk to like a Doobie. Hutch probably should be willing. But
here's the thing, anybody who learns the facts probably doesn't
have positive feelings towards Destiny and probably gets labeled
a snarker pretty quickly.
And so for Hutch, I I just don't know where he's ever going to
get the information he would need to make a good decision here.
Conversation to have with a friend. I've had those kinds of conversations
with friends. People have come to me with those kinds of observations
about me. Those are the kind of friendships that you want. Like
you you want friendships with people that are going to hold you
accountable and not cosign bad behavior. The problem with having
this conversation on a live stream is once you add this element
of an audience then the conversation takes on a whole new meaning.
Because, and I don't pretend to know how Connor's mind works,
but it's possible that in Connor's mind he is like fighting for
his internet life, you know? Like he has this
long established friendship with Destiny. There's there's there's
a ongoing, you could say like work relationship or work acquaintanceship.
as far as I understand, a lot of like audience overlap. And so
there could be these other factors that kind of pervert the conversation
and then and then it becomes about something other than what
you're talking about. I don't know. Does that make sense? I'm
trying to explain myself here.
Like I don't know if they're having a conversation really about
the thing that's being discussed.
It just It doesn't seem like it's about that in this moment.
It seems like it's about something else, you know? Cuz you have
like this audience that are going to be like they're they're
going to be tribalistic with with online communities. And so
you have a lot of people that are like fiercely loyal to Destiny
that are part of his community. And now he's like the villain,
the bad guy in that in that space. And he's probably like experiencing
the consequences of that. I'm sure his mentions look crazy right
now. And maybe that makes him want to dig in more. And maybe
you know, so there's like all these other complicating factors.
It's Basically like all of the things that they're presenting
as a totally evil [__] that I've I've done, like
which is actually pretty much just the reporting thing, they're
all threatening to do to Connor now in a way that I never did,
not even in the worst of times. They're like saying they're going
to call Connor's sponsors. It's just
Dude, it's crazy.
It's crazy how hard they're going. >> So dysfunctional.
This is not how Fake neutrality from Hutch is so cringe,
Yeah. I do wonder just how much of it is intentional and understood.
Do you know what I mean? Like just how much of Hutch's performance
here is him intentionally and and understandably trying to
get that audience on his side. And let me tell you when you when
you 4x your audience size cuz you're giving a certain opinion,
it has a an effect and a feeling on you that is difficult to
Like I think you have to be a very strong person to resist that
at all.
And Hutch is going to be experiencing that a lot. I think he
had 4,000 concurrent viewers earlier today when he's covering
this. Like that is going to be really really hard to resist.
My sponsors, do they just mean Midas? Yeah, I think they do.
these kind of conversations
They named somebody who runs the Valor media thing. Um
when done correctly and done with like good intentions. If your
intention truly
you care about your friend and I I I I I I I I I I I I and you
you want them to make better decisions, then like that that um
that's one thing. But if your intention is to like defend yourself
against like an internet community and and I don't know, it's
just like it it makes these kinds of discussions like literally
impossible in this kind of a setting. Granddad's Lounge with
5 lbs. Problem is D has had these conversations over 3 years
and made the requested changes to his life. That's why even the
Pixie is 3+ years old. Thoughts with D with $10. The thing that
I don't get is let's say Connor's right and Destiny did bring
this on himself. How does it justify folks like Hutch and Wick
getting targeted? Well, I I I I I think that's the point that
that Destiny is like explicitly making, right? Um Adrian with
with $5. I believe Connor has some mental stuff going on and
is using Destiny as a way to lash out. He needs to find a therapist.
Styrofoam. Well, probably everybody in this Discord call.
Dude, you have no idea how often that's Destiny's response to
people just expecting him to be a decent person. You're like
you're like totally mentally unstable. You're like totally mentally
unwell. You're like really really You need to get You need to
get help. I don't know what's happening with you right now, Connor.
Maybe you need to take a week off. Maybe the divorce is just
a bit too much, man. Dude, it's so crazy listening to this happen,
man. That you were an unstable woman who is still
at this moment, and who was married to your political opposition
who wants to you. I just want to ask you one fair question. Who
who gave you this idea that this person is like anything relevant
to any of the past year Who are they talking about, guys? Are
they talking about Lauren Southern?
Who's this person that was married to a groper? Who is this person?
Does anyone even know who the they're talking about? No, different
person? Okay.
I don't know. I don't know. Guys, I can't follow anything. I
just I What is happening, guys?
Guys, what is happening?
I I'm lost. What is happening? What?
and a half of real life harassment towards other people I know,
of harassment towards anybody who was on social media, of interviewing
my court cases, of reaching out to witnesses who he did mentally
unstable woman that you are Her name is it First of all, I'm
not talking about this person right now, okay? Number one. Number
two, she said that I'm not talking to this person right
>> It's so funny watching it happen in real time. The little
corrections.
>> woman that you are Her name is it First of all, I'm
not talking about this person right now, okay? Number one. Number
two, Does Hutch catch any of this? It's so funny, man. Like,
what does he mean by right now? Like, right this second, in the
past day, or Oh, so much of this behavior is aloof maxing, if
you pay attention. Well, hold on. Here's the thing, Evil Johnny
Bravo. The issue for Hutch is that he is this stupid when it
comes to like when it comes to covering politics and stuff, too.
Like, he is just this dumb basically all the time. So, while
it could be aloof maxing, while he could really be trying to
like just sweep this up, he is also quite dumb in regular situations,
like quite incapable of processing information.
So, like it I guess it could go either way. Depends on how much
he watched before he decided to cover this, right?
But, anyway, they're talking about the Britt person that's been
brought up. >> said Is that who she is? Sorry, what? Is
that is she is her name online? She's the one in in JustPearly's
Discord server that reached out to the victim of But if you think
you get [__] Wait, wait, wait, hold on. If You're
you're you're saying Hold on, hold on, hold on. You're saying
I shouldn't care about your life when you're doing something
so reckless and stupid it runs the risk of you getting murdered?
I as your friend shouldn't have criticism of you? The amount
of The amount of pivot sweep that you've done, none of this has
anything to do with my court case. You are desperately running
from it because you know that you can't defend it. >> it
did, you I said that you are s-
and you're dangerous to yourself. Dude, I'm Do you understand?
So, there's this thing Destiny does that he only ever uses other
people's boundaries, I find, when he's done something wrong.
Like if he doesn't want to go to a to a conversation or a situation,
he only uses boundaries of other people. He He doesn't think
about boundaries of other people. He only does it when he's like
trying to protect from something. Which is like, man, he's And
now Connor's saying like, I didn't say that has anything to do
with this. I called you Connor's really mad about him this woman.
I'm thinking Connor is like quite disgusted by whatever conversations
he's had with that couple. You know what I mean? Like there's
something more to this situation. All right, that's good. That
is basically nothing to do with any of the problems that I've
been experiencing for the past 2 years, but unless I get >> You don't
think that you're in a court case right now because you're in
a danger to yourself?
Oh, also, yeah, I guess it does flow quite nicely into the fact
that he started trading homemade that he didn't have consent
to trade with a woman he'd known for 10 days that wasn't a woman
that was pretending to be an 18-year-old girl who was actually
a 26-year-old man who was in fact using the pictures of a 17-year-old
girl. Who was the I was for recording videos with Pixie. I shouldn't
have done that. 6 years ago. >> No. Oh, well, maybe, but
>> Laura and I should have >> you're almost there.
You're
You're saying I just like can't have s- then Connor? Are you
Connor? You're just basically saying that s- is wrong. Okay,
Connor, that's your criticism. You're blowing up our friendship
because you think s- is bad. Is that what it is Connor? Just
the performative
the performative like oh I couldn't possibly understand what
you're actually mad about Connor. I couldn't possibly understand
what you're actually mad about Connor. What what are you actually
mad about? I have no idea what you're actually mad about Connor.
>> Almost at the point that's actually a good point.
Yeah, please please articulate yourself and how it resulted in
a court case. Please do. is you just not liking people having
casual OR DOING
>> NO WAY. WAIT, I DIDN'T KNOW HE ACTUALLY SAID IT. I DIDN'T
KNOW HE ACTUALLY SAID
DUDE, NO SHOT. No
shot. He literally just said it out loud that that is the only
problem. That must be the problem you have Connor. You just don't
like casual
No,
that's are you being sued for casual
No, no, no, no. Me, because I'm a sane adult, I don't like that
my idiot millionaire friend who is wildly intelligent, wildly
successful in so many domains of his thought [__]
that it was smart to send homemade
to random people on the
That's why I'm calling you Jay didn't tell me that, Weeman didn't
tell me that, Doobie didn't tell me that. I thought that you
were myself and I called you
for two
No comment from Hutch by the way. No comments from Hutch. This
is This is Hutch as he listens to this, okay? sane adult I don't
like that my idiot millionaire friend who is wildly intelligent,
wildly successful in so many domains of his life, thought that
it was smart to send homemade
to Like the face is almost doesn't even make sense for what's
being said, right? Like that He's actually bad at capturing a
response to a situation with his face. Like he's facially too.
Like he he's not just slow and unable to retain
He's also like bad at making the face that is appropriate for
the situation.
Genuinely, he looked like he just he looks like he just stepped
outside and the sun's in his eyes. Well, random people on the
[__] internet.
That's why I'm calling you J Scott didn't tell me that. Leeman
didn't tell me that. Doobie didn't tell me that. I thought that
you were myself. Called you for two [__] years. That
makes sense. >> And you're still
If a Justical fan showed up at my home and murdered me because
they were so upset over the court case, would that be my fault?
Sorry, if who showed up and murdered >> A Justical fan
showed up at my home and murdered me because they were so upset
about my behavior. Would You think fans of mine are like really
concerned about this stuff? I mean, I'm sure they are, but do
you think that's like their primary drive at this point or they
watched you be a total psycho who's like threatened people's
safety in this community like all around this
Like which one which one do you think it is? Do you think it's
all the threats? I'd say people in my community who are actually
under threat by you probably they're like pretty upset, no?
At you like directly for your behavior. It's probably you trying
to dox a bunch people, right? Right? Just be real for 2 seconds.
That'd be my fault. How about we change it to the graper? Can
can you >> answer that question? You No no no I I'll answer
your question. Why the [__] do they think you guys
are the really angry ones? There are other communities way more
likely to do that. Like I think Destiny understands this that
he's fought with a bunch of online communities that would hate
him and have long-term antipathy towards him.
And by the way, like I don't want to be real like
it's wrong to do but even if I didn't have a principle against
it it would just be stupid to do. Like I want to do this long-term
on the internet. I don't want to do I don't want to [__]
around with that stuff, right? Like I I I'm principally against
it, but even if I wasn't even if I thought it was like a reasonable
tactic that's on the table because of the downside like socially
or professionally, I wouldn't want to do
You know what I mean? Uh in terms of him, I I also have a principle
and I I wouldn't want to do any of the adjacent stuff either.
The the whole like collateral damage thing is [__]
up. Yeah, it's just not good. Well, it's not good for business
because he's like blaming me for it and he started trying to
do this the same [__] back to people in my community
and I'm just like, "Dude, it's Like I don't Hey, I just You could
just respond to the arguments on stream, man. What the hell?
What is my next timestamp? My next timestamp is
right here. This is where we move forward in the conversation,
okay? Uh Shen with $2, do you think Connor has no valid critique?
Dude, what? Dude. [laughter]
Do I have this sped up, too? Hold on, there's no way I don't
No, I have it on 1x, okay. It's hard for me to give an opinion,
again, because
Like no, I mean, sure, yes. I think I've said that at many, many
points in this stream.
It's not that there's It's not He's going to say something, but
it's like, "It's not that he doesn't have a valid critique. It's
that that is all private and it should be pri- private only."
And like, you should never Dude, what about
violating people's consent with that with the sharp
audio encounters without people's consent? What about that stuff?
Is
it that should not be talked about
He's literally getting sued for it for one thing because of his
sloppiness, because he was somebody that he knew for 10 days
and sending other people's to them. That stuff in the public.
That's his fault.
It's not only his fault, but it is his fault. Like, he is the
person who was the custodian of that and sent it to other people.
He is to blame. Not that it's never appropriate to tell a friend
when you think that they're being self-destructive or impulsive
or making bad decisions. Like of course there are there are contexts
where not only is that appropriate, but that that would be like
the sign of a good friend.
Of course.
>> it's it's the tying
the critique of Destiny's like
social life or romantic life or life. And then tying it into
the conversation about like snarkers
and then that's just gone. Like at some point in the discussion
we're not even we're not even talking about snarkers anymore.
It's just Connor putting Destiny on trial for his sins.
Yeah, so Hutch just doesn't have the context here, right? The
context is that Counter-Points has defended Desti for a very
long time and defended him having a chance to change, right?
And Desti's shown no proclivity for change. Desti has basically
spit in Counter-Points'
by refusing to even entertain change.
And also like a lot of the things that Desti the narratives Desti's
are running with now are so Trumpian and so far away from the
truth that Connor probably feels like guilty or weird in participating
in them, right? Like he's just making things up and
telling his audience it's the way it is with almost no proof
at all. It's just very Trumpian. Connor, in terms of like who's
dangerous to internet politics right now, I would say Desti's
far outstripping Hasan [__] If Desti were to get,
you know, a couple of these snarker people deplatformed or like
just made them run scared through doxing threats and [__]
If he was able to do this enough and stabilize his platform and
get back to politics, why would you want a total psychopath like
that in your political movement? It doesn't make any sense. This
is just not
an appropriate venue for that kind of
You would never have this kind of conversation like this on a
live stream. There's no way any anybody could could justify this
kind of a conversation on on a stream like this. It's just like
we're not even
Why? We're not even talking about sneakers anymore. We're just
It's just like Connor prosecuting this case against Destiny and
hard to make sense of it. I don't really understand where this
is coming from, but I don't really know Connor that well. I don't
really know Destiny that well. I don't really know their friendship
that well. I don't know. I don't know how much they talk behind
the scenes. I genuinely have no idea.
Um Boris with $10 D gets the girl Connor asks out and then lets
her go. It must have made Connor feel small and now he wants
to feel vindicated that he can think it's D's. I'm not going
to speculate on the particulars.
I genuinely
have no idea what is making Connor tick in this moment. Uh the
trip with $5 saying you want Destiny to slow down with his sec
with his what? With his sec is that what you mean? Uh sure, saying
you're running your own life which removes agency from bad actors
is not valid.
Uh he literally is the He is the person who's ruining his own
life. That is I'm sorry. He just is. Nothing I can do can hurt
Destiny unless I'm saying the
Right? I cannot just make things up about Destiny. And that's
why they're getting blown up. That's why That's why Dessy's losing
it so badly because when you just say like blatant lies like
obvious overt lies all the time like him and Dan are doing right
now in this situation, nobody believes you. You You destroy your
credibility. And that's what Destiny had for a long time, right?
That's why he built the audience he did that was so helpful,
that was so useful, that would do so much for him. He's got a
different audience now, but I don't think it's a very good one.
I don't think it's a very strong one. I Like some people are
back, but I think they're back cuz they have empathy for him
as a friend. I don't think they're the kind of people who would
engage in like the [__] that's How do I put it? I
don't think these are the kinds of people that would engage in
the [__] he's doing in terms of like going after
people personally. They might be in the community, they might
want to show solidarity. Like I'm assuming that's how Mouton
came back was basically like somebody reached out to him was
like, "Hey, this guy's like losing it. This guy's having a really
rough time."
You know what I'm saying? Anyway.
I But the the community was there because they liked that he
was driving towards the truth. That's where I was going with
that, right? That he used to be known for driving towards the
truth, the guy who's like based in fact.
And they've gotten so far away from It's like very very very
bizarre. Oh, >> Um Connor Connor originally was bringing
all this up as some kind of a justification, not maybe not a
justification, but like pretense or explanation for like the
snarker behavior. And
he just like lost me right away with that. That's not a reason
to like somebody having
even even even if the behavior is bad
somebody having
uh questionable
just making questionable decisions as it pertains to their love
life is not a justification to the kind of obsession that you
can see in the logs. That's kind of crazy. Dude, the logs dude,
he
Again, he's talking about the obsession. The sad thing is truly
Destiny was not discussed anywhere near as much as people might
think from what these guys talk about, right? Like I do think
Hutch was talked about more in that server. Like I People basically
are like kind of grossed out by Destiny. Like they don't want
to watch him in a lot of different contexts. So, Hutch was talked
about way more cuz Hutch was somebody who like wasn't disgusting.
And he would say really dumb things and it was like funny to
watch him, okay?
It's like one of those people like I assume if you have a really
really dumb enemy, you like laugh at them a lot and you you bring
them up all the time, right? That's sort of what it was with
Hutch was he just would say really stupid [__] all
the time. And so we would watch him and laugh. But I I don't
think Destiny came up anywhere near as much as Hutch. Or I don't
think they came up the same
Maybe Destiny came up nearly as much, but anyway, we keep going.
>> suggest. The implication is like he brought it on himself,
but these these people are are relentless, obsessed, and
very explicitly motivated
to destroy not only Destiny's life, but anybody who comes within
like three degrees of separation from Destiny.
completely
unacceptable behavior. That's wildly disproportionate to
whatever controversies Destiny is involved in from time to time.
Michael with $5 last night's argument was as serene Branson once
said, very, very heavy birdtation.
I don't know what that Hmm, I don't know how much more we've
got of the hot stuff. I'm going to read a few more logs here,
and then we can keep going. I think the next time step I have
is when Wick calls in. Okay?
Dear Greek, is he age playing with me when he tells me to grow
up? Oh my god. Why the [__] would he bring this up?
So cringe. Why would he get this on himself? So cringe. Bro,
this is literally only funny to me because of how clueless Connor
was here. But in retrospect, THIS IS ACTUALLY SO INSANELY GROSS
THAT HE THOUGHT he was ambushing me here. I can't believe this
is my life. NBA player smiling in the rain meme. I don't know
what that meme is.
Valrein, I cannot talk about this because it comes off as insanely
self-grandiosing.
Aggrandizing, I think is what he means. Insanely self-grandiosing,
but a huge psychological driver to a lot of my haters is that
I have way more than I ever deserved to have. And it's hard for
them to reconcile it. I mean, that might be true. I just don't
really care.
That he has way more than he deserves. I just don't super care.
You know what I mean?
Sir, you could say that about a lot of people. I'm sure the In
terms of what people deserve in this world, you don't get what
you deserve. You know what I mean? You don't get what you've
earned. You Like it's the world's not fair.
I don't let that That doesn't [__] with me. I don't
know about other people. Example, I'm short, not super built
or anything. There's no world where I should be banging hot chicks.
I'm very aggressive and mean sometimes, but don't ride it with
any political group. There's no way I I should have an audience,
but I do. I'm not particularly well educated. I don't come from
money or any amazing genetics talk or anything. So, I shouldn't
do as well as I do for debates. For all these points, people
have to find it obsess over the specific copes. Otherwise, they
can't handle their own lives are. Example, well, girls just want
him for his money or because he abuses or manipulates them. Or
well, he only has an audience because he brainwashes the cult.
Or well, he's not a good debater or smart. He just tact uses
tactics on people. You'd be sixes if you didn't have money and
clout. That's just facts.
May maybe not sixes, man. To be honest with you. I'm just saying
it's the money and clout thing 100%.
Um well, he only has an audience because he brainwashes the cults.
No, you used to be funny.
You're like funny and edgy back in the day. That's why you have
an audience.
You've totally lost your sense of humor. You got no humor to
you anymore. This guy sucks at making jokes, man. Terrible. He
used to be really good at
He'd like really funny moments, right? Funny [__]
would happen on the stream.
Okay? And then, well, he only has an audience because he brainwashes
the cult. We did that. Well, he's not a good debater or smart.
He just uses tactics on people. Oh, this is This is one. He's
not a bad
But he will just yell over people when he doesn't have the facts
on his side. He just used to just He just used to debate the
facts. He'd basically say, what are the things that you prove
the most? And then he would drive people towards having to engage
with like the facts that he found to prove his opinion. That's
what he was really good at, right? In my opinion. Um and then
he would get anytime it would got close or that he was really
out of his depth, he would just get he essentially kind of asked
for turf the reaction to the debate. It's my opinion.
>> I don't have to like take away the fact that he was
able to build an audience, man. Yeah, I don't know social export.
It's it's very Like I I feel like there's no way he could that
cloudy. Like that like I could not remember it that badly. Anyway,
every part of my life and success has to be explained by some
insane cope that just get gets amplified a million times
Okay, I dude, who's even doing this? Where where is this self-victimization
coming from? Okay, it unfolded fast because there's a huge community
of people who are trying to spin them up 1 million percent.
With Connor?
Dude, well, I will say
every time every time well, not every time cuz it would have
been a lot every time. But my DMs with Connor are basically like
whenever Destiny does something insanely like antisocial that
would get most influencers canceled to me, I just shoot it over
to Connor. I don't even like I don't go to a bunch of people
and talk about it. I do shoot it over to Connor though. Like
look at what this guy just did. Look at this psycho. Look at
this psycho. Look at this
Look at this psycho. Look at the And by the way, Connor would
either say that I don't really care about this, I don't know
what that is, or he he basically like shot all of them down.
Look at him coming to my chat saying
Look at him trying to like say he thinks my dad died on Twitter
and how funny that is. Like I By the way, none of it none of
Destiny's affects me, right? It it just doesn't. It's just like
par for the course, really not a problem. But it's I just sent
it to Connor cuz I'm like, "Look, he's crashing out. Your buddy's
crashing out. Your buddy's losing it."
So, for Connor alone I would say, you know, I did I did actually
send stuff to him cuz I was just like, "Oh, I think you actually
care." I thought I thought there was a human being somewhere
in there. Anyway, we keep going. Every part of my life such success
to be explained away by some insane cope. He did that one. So,
steelman the other side, Hutch, please.
Okay, I'll go. My KF reeks of this type of theorizing about my
life. It is so funny such insane to see the depths they have
to go to to justify or explain my
Uh yeah, your KF friend probably thinks They don't like you.
Lauren has zero reason to have her [__] leaked out
on the internet.
Well, why were you sharing it around to so many people then?
Why'd did DM all of the Lauren Southern to so many people? Well,
What was going on there? You What are you doing, man? What are
you doing? What are you doing? What are you doing? What are you
doing? What are you doing?
It's actually insane. He keeps doing it. Lauren and me mutually
agreed to split 2 months ago because our lifestyles were way,
way, way too different. She is a bit more in her, I want to do
more serious, let's settle down media kind of stuff, and I am
still very much in the I am fighting FOR MY LIFE EVERY DAY. I
LOVE THE BATTLE. LET'S GO, MY BROTHERS, among other things.
Yeah, you're having a great time. You're having a great time,
man. I can tell. I can tell he's having a fantastic time.
There is no bad blood or bad feelings or anything. Connor is
dragging all of this out publicly for literally no reason. What
the
What? Can't take criticism. Oh my god. This is THE MOST HEY,
FYI, FYI, FYI, FYI, FYI.
In case you're listening to this as a human being, the most insane
abuse you can ever get as a person is someone treating you like
Well, constantly saying, "I'M ONLY DOING this because I love
you." Okay. Um How many times has Connor talked to you in private
about stuff like this or just mentioned it to you? And like now
it has to be public if he feels like I I'm just saying. Brandon,
I feel almost every online relationship to be on a timer, to
be honest. It's just the way things go. Okay, what offline relationship
for Destiny is also not on a timer? Which What relationships
for Destiny aren't on a timer? Like honestly, honest to god.
Which ones? Oh, this is today. Yeah, this is today while the
Hutch stream is going on. It's the way things go. Although, I
feel like I'm getting such a clear picture of things over the
past year or more after seeing how that circle place operates.
Try not to fall too deep into the schizo thing, but I feel like
places have been operating like this for so long in ways that
I just haven't fully appreciated.
Like realistically, what this is is there's like communities
that are operating somewhat like DGG chat. Like that's honest
to god what's happening that he's so upset about. That there's
another community spinning up that operates just a little bit
like DGG
And he's one of the people that doesn't like, but there are a
lot of people that it like doesn't not huge fans of.
You know what I mean? Like that's what he's upset about. It's
It what happened What did they What did they talked about? These
guys search logs,
DGG chat behavior. These guys compile like like facts or patterns
of patterns of facts that show how harmful a person could be.
Well, what else did Willy Mac learn this from if not the output
of DGG chat being recorded on the DGG subreddit? What else did
he make his videos based on? You know what I mean?
That's what this is all been. It just slowly moves in the same
direction as DGG chat. It's
And and anything like this existing somewhere else on the internet
is like just abuse to him. It's abuse, it's crazy. Anyway, guy
types like he's writing for a gay anime show. He does a lot of
anime villain monologuing. Yes, he does. Though I feel like I'm
getting such a clear picture of things over the past year or
more after seeing how that Snark the place operates. Trying not
to fall too deep into the schizo thing, but I feel like places
have been operating like this for so long in ways that I just
really haven't fully appreciated. Remember Vaush came from one
of those communities a long time ago. Reddit says, dude. There's
no way There's no way that this guy's talking about like snarker
communities when he's been operating the biggest snarker community
on the internet for like a decade. How in the world does he not
understand that the Name a behavior
that any of the communities you're mad at engage in that your
community does not engage in.
That's all you got to do, man. And they engage in similarish
behavior. Not saying Vaush is one of these people. I think me
and him are similar in demeanor. I think he would get bored being
at spaces like this to be honest.
Okay, holy projection. Holy projection.
I didn't invite her to that event. I didn't pay for her ticket.
WE DIDN'T FLY TOGETHER. WE WEREN'T IN the same hotel.
She was in the audience. It's not like I could tell her she's
not allowed to come to the state slash event. Holy
Uh yeah, you could.
Dude, didn't you let her stay at your place for like a month
after that event?
Didn't she fly back to like Miami and stay in your home for like
a month after What do you mean you can't ask her not to show
up at the event? Yes, you can. Hey, you spit on people and then
call them on the internet. You can't be at my political event.
That would be horrible.
Look, it just happened. Look how easy that was.
I've never even seen her naked.
We did not touch. We did not touch or do
I did not touch that woman. I DID NOT
that insane woman. I did not. I did not. I did not.
Okay, bro. Okay, man.
WHAT WAS THE DATE, ACTUALLY, FOR THAT EVENT? TELL ME THE DATE
FOR the event. What was the date with Dyrus in the bad chat?
The reason we said no was because Connor was the one who leaked
it the first time. He was the first one to leak or confirm it
last time. Well, technically no, somebody else confirmed it last
time. And I believe Melina leaked it before Connor did.
Did Melina not leak it like all over the place before Connor
did? Mr. Girl knew about it. I could have sworn that Melina was
the one who was like leaking, unless you mean publicly Connor
like acknowledging it once. I think Connor just [__]
up, though.
Connor giving his final thoughts. Let's catch up on the logs
and then we'll go back to that, okay? Our travel plans. We're
not even the same. We're not even the same. Hello mayo. We did
not stay together or fly back together or anything. She didn't
even know where I was staying that day. He didn't even know what
day I was
Let me leak more and more info about my personal LIFE TO SATISFY
EVERYONE ON THE INTERNET. YES.
Who wants to see my
Just kidding. There are 30 videos of me out there already. Haha.
Come on, man. Come on. Come on. Come on.
It's rough. It's very rough, man.
No, we fun-loving regular guy. No, we didn't. I left without
her. She wasn't aware I was even leaving that day. DONALD TRUMP
LITERALLY INVITED THIS mistress to a VACATION WITH HIS WIFE.
there's no He's It's so insane. How do you go to that? And you
go to Donald Trump literally invited his mistress to a vacation
with his wife. LIKE OKAY. DONALD TRUMP IS THE FIRST PRESIDENT
TO GET CONVICTED OF 34 FELONIES related to him lying ABOUT PAYING
OFF A LAWYER for a porn star. He's the president of the United
States.
[__] days thing is a huge talking point of the farms.
King, I never even said that. Ever LMFAO. FBI Wait, hold on.
You didn't say that. You didn't say that, but I do believe that's
like indicated by the logs. I I'm pretty sure he's basically
acknowledged
I never said that. Ever. FBI literally told me exactly who's
making these threats. LMFAO.
I've never said this in my life.
Um you've said it was my fault you got calls from the FBI. You've
said that multiple times.
You've literally said this on your stream. Why are you presenting
This is a super long messy story, BUT IT'S KIND OF for me to
bring it up because for me to give my side of anything casts
everyone in different light. These two people are not public
people at all, but I'm sure their friends are and people they
know are watching. So for me to say anything at all for about
this particular situation will take all of their personal business
up and throw it into the public light. So sending his wife's
to somebody he doesn't know from a hole in the ground totally
fine. Him discussing the age play dynamics that he engaged in
with this person totally insane. He would never ever do that.
That That behavior is like the shock behavior for me for he did
something [__] up here.
He doesn't think about other people's boundaries or protecting
their privacy or protecting their safety until he can weaponize
it to defend himself.
This is this there's something going on here. He does it so often,
right? Like the Rose thing is the was the perfect example was
the quintessential example of this.
Right? He was trying to dox Rose to get her in the case. Then
when she was deposed it came out that she was a minor. Well,
sorry, she then people found out she was minor. Then it came
out that she didn't even have access to those accounts since
she was trafficked, right? Like technically it's some kind of
trafficking to sell those pictures like what she's in that relationship.
But you don't even learn that she wasn't selling them herself
or she didn't have access to the accounts until the
So he helped to dox her, then she was found and deposed and somehow
he moralized the idea of deposing her. Well, also purportedly
wanting to dox her to depose her for the case because she had
important information for the
The judge himself literally said we should probably get this
person in here.
They didn't know that she wasn't sending the messages until she
was deposed.
So there's just no rational way to say that it was up to reach
out. When did he message her on Facebook? After she was doxed
as well, yes, directly. Kind of weird, kind of a weirdo move
to be honest with you.
Very odd. So again, just the idea of like, oh I I should never
ever do this. It would be really wrong of me to do that. He doesn't
care about other people's privacy until
he needs to weaponize it to protect himself. Very clear every
time. This is this is the exact behavior. But would anyone ever
subject someone to that? Both of the parts of that couple WERE
LITERALLY BEGGING CONNOR TO stop leaking and publicizing anything.
All right, we keep going.
If I get murdered or killed or whatever, please send all my audience
and everything to Hutch. Oh my god, I just understood all the
I cannot believe how I am. I just realized dude presents all
of these crazy stupid backstories so
said he has a good reason never to be doxed. He does this to
shield his identity. He's so full of
>> Mate, how the [__] I? Did everyone else
get this tip but not me?
>> I paired up pedals with Dubie. Who the [__]
is this hanging out with? I'm taking today off to catch up on
everything I keep start starting late because I am so buried
by so many DMs and emails related to this I need to catch up.
He's having a plotting day. Okay. He's having a plotting day.
Very interesting. Very cool.
Very sick.
Ooh, we have a Connor update. We have a Connor update. He has
been blocked on
It may be over. It may actually be over,
Connor's been blocked apparently. Hold on.
He's been blocked.
There's a post.
I'm making large changes to my life going forward. THERE'S NO
WAY.
2027 IS THE YEAR THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET IT ALL RIGHT, GUYS.
We're cutting all the toxic people out of our lives. We're leaving
all the toxic people in 2026.
Say the line, Bart. SAY THE LINE, BART.
>> WE'RE LEAVING ALL THESE TOXIC PEOPLE IN 2026, GUYS.
And they're all staying back
Uh it's so it's crazy. I'm going to be creating a watch council.
It will appoint six people, two of my own vote choosing, two
voted for on by chat, and two voted on by my closest group of
friends. Before I engage with any individual on a or friendship
level, I will have the council vote upon this engagement, and
it will require at least 4/6 of them to approve it. What is this
like? This is like Cosby saying that you know, making up a tweet
about how Okay, I guess every single person who accepts a drink
in my house from now on is just going to have to like have that
drink drug tested. I guess that's that's reasonable, guys. I
guess. I guess Like, okay. I You're You're being silly right
now. Come on, man. Come on, man. Be serious
for 2 seconds.
Now, Wick is particularly like rodent-like. Okay, he's particularly
rat-like when it comes to this I think we should probably pull
the Reddit post as well. I can't remember if this before after
the hot conversation,
Anna versus Destiny part two. This was incredibly sad.
He's forgotten how to be human.
You see someone you consider a friend being harassed, attacked,
literally they are trying to destroy his life.
They're coming at him, his child, anyone who works with him,
anyone who's simply insufficiently
He's losing his friends, losing support,
He's drowning. Dude.
He's the victim. He's the biggest victim here. He's the biggest
victim, guys.
it's crazy. Now,
I don't know like
I think I've linked a grand total of like maybe three of Nathan's
tweets anywhere that could be trackable on the internet. Like
to laugh at it's mostly him like saying something funny like
on his dad. I've never covered on stream. I've explicitly banned
him from my community and banned discussion of him in my community.
So like basically, I've I feel like I've no responsibility in
terms of going after his child. Nobody could ever make that argument
about me,
Like in terms of any of the commentary being made about Nathan
or anything going on there, so it's just not real. Anyone who's
simply insufficiently anti-Destiny. This is not not true, right?
The issue is Wick lies. If Wick wouldn't lie in terms of how
he wants to coordinate with Destiny or cooperate with Destiny,
if he wouldn't lie and change his community rules and piss everybody
off, like this is his problem. It's a Wick problem. It's not
a anti-Destiny problem. It's not a Stalker problem. It's just
a Wick problem. Anyway, so Wick is, you know, self-victimizing,
making Destiny the biggest victim. Okay, let's take a look.
I don't know what to do here or if I should do anything. Who
am I after all? I have a professional relationship with both
of these gentlemen.
I am not their friend, strictly
We are friendly, but there is a
Should I have even stepped in? Frankly, no. This all should have
been done in private. But they were doing it in public, and I
happened to see it. All of this All of this madness.
It made me consider how I engage.
Maybe keeping professional distance has been a
They seem to need friends right now. Hell, I know I do. I'll
talk more about this on Monday, but it's been incredibly disheartening
to see how many people consider everything happening to me to
be just content.
I get this is all super soy, but I am soy. I embrace it, I suppose.
All this to say,
and I know this is a bit of stream of consciousness rant, but
streaming makes us forget how to be human a bit.
My appeal to you, dear viewer, remember, we're not just streamers.
We are human beings.
Give us all some grace.
Okay. All right. That was a little nauseating to do for that
long. That was [__] up.
Let me make sure I've got the timestamp for the Wick call-in.
Here we go. Here we go. Hey, what's up, man?
I was watching you cover this little bit. Uh I was curious you'd
take it. Uh it's pretty based, okay? Your kind of intuition here
kind of follows mine, but um I think it I I tried to to tell
Connor this
All of the low IQ terrible entertainers are following the same
intuition, which is not shocking. >> um over the last 2
days, but I don't think he was listening to me. Uh but there's
like context to all this that I think
should be known.
What is the context? >> clear, I don't have like uh all
the information. I don't have access to the logs or anything
like these things, but I do know information, right? That does
put a lot of this into context, just based on my experiences
previously and what's happening to me right now. Uh that uh it
might help not only you, but your audience to kind of understand
what's going on. All right. This was
a successful
op. These people
Conner into a weapon
and watched him immolate himself live on
Um in order to further isolate >> you suspect that or do
you know that for sure? I suspect it. >> I suspect it because
I'll tell you why. Yeah. So, the other day
I got wind that Destiny was going to change his rules. That he
was going to start banning anyone who had Duby in their space.
And
this is something that people started DMing me, right? And I
saw people start talking about it. You know, the same names I
usually see, right? Saying, "Ooh, you stood up for Destiny and
he's going to kick you out. Ooh, look, Destiny's going to blacklist
you. Haha, after all you did." Right? And kind of putting these
seeds out there, right? Kind of creating this impression that
this was going to happen.
Um I reached out to Destiny. We had a
short, productive talk live on air, right? I said, "Hey,
His rules. Rules for what, Wick? Rules for his slaves? Yeah,
it's like, "I'm going to do my boundaries that are actually boundaries
for how you run your professional like your you the your little
profession, your job. My boundaries as a friend are here's how
you do your job.
Here's how you write code or some [__] right? Dude,
what?
How can that be a part of your friendship boundaries? That seems
crazy.
I um I'm not comfortable banning someone from my community that
hasn't broke the rules, uh but I understand that you have legitimate
concerns. What can we do? Um and we got to compromise. I didn't
have to ban anyone from my server. I said, "Okay, well, I'll
just let you if you're concerned that my space is being used
as like a snarker pep rally, uh you can come into my space anytime,
right? And see what's going on, and I'll give you full access
to the VCs and all that, and you can go in and check all you
want." Um that way I didn't have to ban anyone.
And he can see if there is snarker pep rallies going on in my
server or not. I thought it was a decent compromise, not perfect,
but it allowed me to kind of
By the way, I believe this like really pissed people off in the
wig cord cuz they like having the no recording of VCs rule. And
they basically gave like Destiny an all-access pass to go and
record the VCs. And I think they also found out that people in
Destiny's communities had been recording those VCs for a long
time, and the response to them recording those VCs and then forcing
Wick via an ultimatum to make a decision there was Wick was like,
"Okay, I capitulate entirely on the recording."
You know what I mean? Very goofy, very sad. >> space and
keep my rules without
entirely compromising
um everything I wanted to do. So, I know what was happening to
me at that time, and how people were reacted to me at that time.
I suspect they were also doing this to Connor. I suspect they
were also in his ear saying, "Cool. Mhm. After all you've done,
Destiny's going to blacklist you. Destiny's going to cut you
off, man. He's threatening you. Look, you got to stand up to
him. You got to have a spine. You got to have a backbone. He's
going to burn you, man. You got You got to take control."
And uh well, it created uh the situation that we find ourselves
in today. Um that's why
Uh I didn't say that to Connor. I actually Yeah, I don't know
who would have been saying that to Connor. Cuz like I heard him
say that a couple
Right? That Oh, well, I'm not going to let you tell me what to
do. I don't think I ever really made that point to Connor. I
don't Like listen,
You want to have like or you want to
capitulate to this guy's neuroses, that's fine. Especially like
a temporary
I don't understand why Like why people would even Sorry, I don't
understand how Wick thinks like snarkers, quote unquote, would
be mad about that. For Wick, I think it was mostly his community
that was pissed about that. Right? I'm guessing for Connor, it
might be people who are pissed in his community, too. I'm not
sure.
Threatening you. Look, you got to stand up to him. You got to
have a spine. You got to have a backbone. He's going to burn
you, man. You got You got to take
And oh, well, it created uh the situation that we find ourselves
in today. Um, that's why I suspect what I did. And I I'm I'm
pretty confident with my analysis here. What do you think from
outside perspective? There's There's things that I know that
I can't that I can't like say.
But uh let's Why Why would there be Dude, like the very idea
that you're going to go and just get everybody to like stay on
board with you never releasing things, but you're going to make
all kinds of allegations. It's so gay, man. It's so unfathomably
Dude, it's so crazy. I don't think Wick understands what he's
saying here. He's just effectively said that having a spine is
dumb. Well, I mean I'll be honest, having a spine can be
Like I don't know if you watched the segment yesterday on Chud
Sourcing Support, but I basically argued that for Chud, having
a spine would be dumb. Like actually, you shouldn't have a spine
in this situation. I totally get it. You got a kids, you got
a mortgage. Yes, you I get it. All I'm asking is for you not
to be an anchor. That's all. Don't be an anchor on the people
who do want to do that, who do want to stand with a spine in
this situation. You know what I mean?
That's all.
Sometimes if Wick wants to say that, if Wick is like I can't
if he's going to capitulate and say I can't make a go of this
in any way unless I'm subservient to Destiny, so I had to maintain
that bridge. He wants to be honest about that, that's fine.
To me,
but you should be honest about it. It shouldn't be like oh, you're
standing on principle and you're doing this to like make sure
you run the space you the way you want. You were running the
space the way you wanted. You're not anymore. Now you're running
it the way somebody else wanted. And you're leaving out all the
stuff that's important there, which is you don't think you could
make a go of it unless you did that. Say I'm Am I Am I Am I Am
I close?
I would say I'm I'm vibing with what you're saying. I'm following
what you're saying. Yeah.
It It does appear just like publicly
just based on like public information
that uh
their whole thing is is like infiltrating other spaces and then
using those spaces as like a proxy
fight with Destiny. That That appears to be happening like just
out in the open.
And um yeah, the whole thing is just like very dark I got banned
for from J's Doc server for potential doxxing lol.
I'm pretty sure that person has posted doc stuff as well, but
whatever. Keep >> like that I find it all very disturbing.
It's all very dark and disturbing like that level of involvement
and emotional investment and uh obsession and Let's be clear,
this is like the the least of it. Um I mean, I I got doxxed,
right? And not only me. And I And I talked to him, right? Just
Does Wick understand that his doxxing is like absolutely like
not connected to the Snarker server?
Like does he understand that? That his name would have been out
publicly due to the PB filings and Old Man Laundry's article
before that? And that that information being posted in that server
was after he was originally doxxed, at least the name?
Like does Wick really have no concept of this whatsoever?
Like I I don't know.
That That just feels bizarre to me that Destiny knows that his
friends like have like because of how he's run his career
there's a KF threat. Well, maybe I won't even say that. There
is a KF threat. Like cuz obviously KF could have a problem with
you even if you weren't like some crazy problematic person. So,
without even casting judgment on that part, although I do have
that judgment, I'll say that he has a KF threat where and he's
had it for a long time since maybe '23, '22 where they've been
doxxing people around him, right? '23 at least I think.
he doesn't inform his friends about this? He doesn't keep an
eye on it or have somebody to keep an eye on it so he could inform
his friends if like their information's posted? Does he have
no concern about that whatsoever?
Like that just seems totally to me that you don't let these people
know at all this [__] that's going on. Like Wick
Wick should know the PV filings were how his information got
out and then multiple people have published that information
before the Starker Discord ever had that information in there.
Now, that doesn't mean it's not doxxing if somebody was doing
that to harass, right? If somebody was doing that hoping someone
would go and harass Wick with it. It doesn't mean it wasn't something.
Person still got banned. But obviously
Wick thinks that like something unique happened there. I'm telling
you Wick, this is not the first time your your stuff has been
on like some public forum.
I'm sorry to inform you of that. It's just not. Like he's now
Now he's talking about it openly so I don't feel bad saying it.
But this was not the first time this happened. Nobody wants to
point it out because obviously it is like a disservice to you
in some way if you haven't acknowledged this [__]
and talked about it openly.
Anyway, we keep going. >> make sure that it was they were
okay with with me sharing. I I talked to one last night. Um Uh
Tally got doxxed because of her relationship with me and Destiny.
Stardust got doxxed. We're not talking just like Destiny and
them talking Destiny. They're talking targeting people associated
with Destiny, even very, very loosely. It is been going on for
months.
For months. >> Probably probably probably over a year.
Uh at this point. >> have no idea. Um but people like Queenman,
people like uh J Stock and all these people are encouraging and
facilitating this behavior. And it's not doxing Evidence. Evidence.
Evidence. Evidence. Evidence. Evidence. Evidence. Evidence. Evidence.
Evidence. Evidence.
You don't get to make this allegation and then [__]
off and never say anything about the evidence. You don't get
to do that. Evidence.
I it's so crazy, man. I don't like what do you even say to like
Oh yeah, there's there's like total skitzos doxing a bunch of
people and Wick is just going to go put a target on other people's
back. Okay, well >> all of it. It's constant harassment.
Um I've I've clips of Queenman uh from maybe a year Wick can't
pretend not to know Queen because Wick had Queen in blacklisted,
right? So Wick can't pretend not to know him. >> here maybe
two years ago. I'm not not sure off the top of my head. Basically
uh painting me as a uh someone who assaults women. Yeah, I saw
that. >> Because he found a picture of me, right?
uh at at TwitchCon with my arm around a woman or something, right?
and painting me as all these things. Just the most slanderous,
libelous
And this is what they do. And they say it's a joke, but this
is a constant thing. This is not a joke. They are not This is
a motte and bailey they do. They'll pretend it's a joke if they
get caught, but they'll treat it seriously
if they can. Mhm. And it is insane.
These people are insane.
And I tried to tell Counter-Points this. I tried to tell Connor
this. I tried to be like, "Bro, like I I don't have a smoking
gun for you, but I don't need a smoking gun for you to know that
these people are all connected to know to know that all these
people are constantly just going through all your data, all your
posts, everything. Like right now, they're You don't need I mean,
you would need Okay, your post. We go through your public content.
That is obviously true. That we do watch your public content.
What is the evidence that we go through like all of your data
or something like this? Like I'm so sorry, Wick, that you were
doxxed by the PB filings. I've read that that article on stream
once Ludwig like updated it and removed the doxx from the main
article. I've watched it on stream. They're they're watching
right now, right? In the stream, they had tons of people spamming
Do you like Zepeto? But Queen Mary Wick a creep a few years ago.
Uh Queen Mary pushed it probably like right up to the line.
He explained to me what he did last
in that conversation last night, dude. He um
I think he said that Wick touched the thigh of Madam No, Madam
Genevieve and
Ginger Amarath.
He said he touched them like non-consensually.
Cuz they asked Ginger, "Did Wick ask for consent before touching
your thigh?" And she said, "No, he didn't." But not saying that
he was like a something like that. So, Queen Mary says, "Well,
Wick touched her
And it sounds a certain way. It's like strictly correct, but
it sounds a certain way. Obviously, he's doing something there
cuz he finds it funny.
He's a little psycho, man. He's a little >> Hi to snarkers.
How you doing? And they're workshopping what to do, what to say,
how to spin it, all these things. And they're going into communities
and they're going into streamers' heads and they're getting into
your head and it's insane. So, for Counter-Points to not even
allow us to have that discussion.
And instead, he decided to litigate
Destiny's life. Who the [__] cares about Destiny's
life? The trial of Steven Destiny Bonnell and
sins. Yeah. He does not He's very very He was very very um emotionally
[clears throat] invested in it and and uh it was it was a little
uh Well, he because they primed him. They primed the pump. They've
been feed like they've been spitting in his ear uh playing to
his suspicions. They've been finding weaknesses and it's a strat
and they won last night. Like Counter-Points, this did not have
to happen how it happened. Um what do you mean won last night?
When was the last time we didn't win?
I I get When was the last time we didn't win, man?
I but I tried to stop it. I tried to calm him down, but I failed.
I just straight up I failed. Um Well, he >> got he got
activated and once he got activated, I mean Connor, once he got
activated, there's no You can't really It's hard to talk people
down when they're in that kind of a place.
I know. It should not have happened publicly. Like look, that
if if they have friendship troubles like that, um that should
have been a private conversation.
I have no idea why
Counter-Points decided to litigate that um on a stream. I have
no idea.
But that If I have a problem with someone as a friend, um
Yeah, I I don't I don't That's not content. It's something else
and uh Dude, it's it's so crazy that this is the way they see
it.
Like I could easily talk to Wick about this, right?
I could easily talk to Wick about this.
I don't know why Wick keeps saying that this is a problem. This
is like a huge issue. Connor just ambushed him. Connor was waiting
for Destiny. Destiny wanted that conversation.
And clearly Destiny was saying this isn't a problem. It's a thing
from way long ago. It's been It's crazy. It's like so long ago.
You're only litigating things for a year or two ago. Two years
ago. And Connor goes, "Dude, I had a problem with you like a
week ago over Like this problem is now. So Destiny's trying to
lie and say, "Well, all the problems that people have a thing
with, they happened way so they happened so long ago that you
shouldn't even litigate them anymore." And Connor goes, "Hey,
you're just lying."
You're just lying. Here's something I was talking to you about
very recently. I don't know, man. I'm I'll just say this all
all is escalating and I don't know how to put the toothpaste
back in the tube. I don't know I don't know what to do. Yeah,
I don't know either. It's crazy.
It seems like these guys have have have
I mean like the snarkers have like it's it's now they've now
assimilated all of this conflict as a like a like a big part
of their
Like a big part of their identities. And for as long as that
remains true, then I don't think they're going to stop. They're
going to keep being obsessed and
with people that have even like five degrees of separation
uh Destiny or or even people like you or Lonerbox or whatever.
You don't have five degrees of separation, you lying
You went on a You had a fight with Pisco and you went on Destiny's
stream for a post like a post-debate debrief.
Hey, how did I do? Hey, how did I do,
How did I do?
You're like an embarrassing loser.
And I tried I gave this guy the benefit of the doubt. That's
the up thing. I gave him the benefit of the doubt and I said,
"You know, we're not going to have to We don't have to like call
him a DGG or whatever. Like I get he feels disconnected from
that community." And I I his position was But then he totally
lied and he went back on that position. He totally capitulated.
He said I would need to see some form of like apology. I would
need to see some form of making things right. I need to see some
acknowledgement.
And him trying to become a better person. That has not happened.
Not even a little bit. And Hutch ended up going and interacting
with him and collabing with him again. I'm going to hold you
that principle now. When you say that you need to see some acknowledgement,
some apology, an effort to become better.
None of those things have happened. You are a liar.
Anyway, and it's just transparently for money and clout. Come
on, man. >> Whatever. Like as long as you know, yeah. Yeah,
it's it's it's something where it's it's a a very effective thing
to continually put out the
to flood the zone with [__] and basically say something
loud enough, often enough, retweet it, get your friends to retweet
it, get your buddies to like it and say variations of that, have
people react to the streams where it happens and then react to
those reacts and all these things to create this like public
perception of what's happening that is not based in truth at
all. And there's again evidence
that I haven't seen all of to be clear, but I've I've seen enough
that I'm I'm very confident that this is a coordinated,
purposeful
strategy that they're engaging in and it's cellular.
Meaning that some of them are directly engaged and some of them
are indirectly engaged so that they have plausible
And I don't know how to I don't know how to deal with it or fix
it, but people have to
when Substance puts a a clip in the chat and just says juice
it, when Substance puts like a clip in and just says juice the
tweets, guys. That's like a complicated, complex scheme that
nobody's ever thought of before. Except like everybody on the
internet ever. >> it's happening. And to be clear, they've
This is they've done it to me. Like people in DGG who or who
have DGG tags will come to me and say, "Well, Destiny actually
really hates you. Destiny actually thinks you're He's making
fun of you all the time." And they're Okay.
I need proof of that. I need proof of that. I need proof of that
now. Give me proof of that
trying to drive that wedge, but it I don't I don't believe that.
I don't believe that. I feel like that's If that's happened more
than once,
like I I can maybe believe some schizos doing that, but the idea
that there's multiple people doing it, get off, man. Nobody cares
about Wick that much. I'm sorry, WICK. YOU'RE NOT IMPORTANT.
You're literally not important at all. >> It's an op, right?
It's an op.
Yeah, they They were They were baiting me for
They were And I didn't become aware of it until You're You're
confusing baiting you with making fun of you for being a They're
different. They're different >> little mole hit me up.
And then it when I saw the level of bait, I felt so
These guys baited me so many times, bro. So many times. And it
was so coordinated. It was so organized. It's embarrassing. And
so now it made me reevaluate stuff. And so now I'm like just
suspicious and so So. Yeah. >> My mission now is to just
make people
and to make as many people aware as possible. And like I said,
I I don't have any smoking guns for you. I don't have all the
pieces of the puzzle. But you know how when you build a puzzle,
there's a point where even if you don't have all the pieces together,
you know what you know it's a you know what it's a picture of.
It's a picture of a clown or a zoo or whatever. >> Well, so
much of it so much of it happened just right in the open. Like
so, you know. I I think yeah, I don't think you need access to
the logs to see
what was going on there. I mean love I love that Hutch reacted
to Hutch my contact. I love that. I love that for him. I'll see
you later, man. Thanks for coming on. I appreciate it. Of course.
Bye. Bye-bye.
Yeah, I've no idea. So, Wick comes on and implies that we're
doxers. There is a Discord we're in where a picture of Wick with
like a like his name was in
With the message was deleted very quickly. Apparently, the artifact
from the Twitter bot stayed there for a
Other than that, it's like, dude, it's nothing. They've got nothing.
It's like that [__] That [__] that happened.
I wish that hadn't happened to
But, it doesn't mean I'm to blame for stuff that was already
out there, man. I'm sorry.